a new report suggests the u.s. may be
flying spy planes over the Korean
Peninsula because of rising tensions
with North Korea Kim jong-un's regime
had hinted four days about a quote
Christmas gift if the US did not East
sanctions before the end of the year
Barry Peterson is in Seoul South Korea
Barry it appears nothing happened on
Christmas but what what exactly was this
threat from from the north
well that Christmas gift could come at
any time and it could be anything from a
ballistic missile launch to a nuclear
weapons test and you know it might just
be rhetoric nothing but that designed to
keep the world on edge it is sparking
action reports a for u.s. reconnaissance
flights an unusually high number at the
same time over the area including a
Global Hawk drone which may be the one
South Korea put into service just this
week there are also satellite images of
a testing area and signs of recent burns
that could be from a new rocket engine
for US soldiers here Christmas came with
dinner and presents from home many loved
family back in the US making this a
lonely job reginal Hill is from Arkansas
it's one of those times especially
around you know the Christmas time is
festive and you think of family and
being separated from my wife is rough
most of the soldiers are members of the
Army's 2nd Infantry Division whose motto
is ready to fight tonight if there ever
really was a fight with North Korea
those young Americans would be the first
in harm's way
Dana Mary Peterson in South Korea Thank
You Barry
you